[Music]
foreign
[Music]
director of product management from
Google cloud and I'm joined by my
colleague Jerome Sims I am r
and we're both excited to share with you
some new products and capabilities we're
introducing at next this year at Google
Cloud our mission is to accelerate every
organization's journey to digitally
transform the business and when it comes
to devops we serve customers of all
sizes and types today and our goal is to
make devops on Google Cloud
easy for your organization as well and
to fulfill this Mission we focus on four
key areas which address the key
challenges we hear from these customers
every day this year we are launching
many new products and capabilities
across all of these four areas and now
I'm going to hand over to my colleague
Jerome to tell you more thanks Amar
software supply chain security is
becoming an increasingly critical
concern for many devops teams and to
help you better protect your software
Supply chains we're very excited to
bring you software delivery Shield
software delivery Shield is a
comprehensive yet modular set of
capabilities that spans a set of Google
Cloud products
delivering a fully managed end-to-end
solution to help protect your software
supply chain to help you better secure
your applications during development we
are launching Cloud workstations
a new service which provides a fully
managed local development environment on
Google cloud with built-in security
measures we are also giving your
developers tools to help them code
faster with greater security
with Cloud code Source protect
developers will get real-time security
feedback as they work in their IDE when
your developers are coding in Cloud
workstations artifact registry and
container analysis can give them a
secure space to store and manage their
container images and language packages
and also scan them for vulnerabilities
you can now do on-push scanning for
Maven and go packages in containers and
for non-containerized Maven packages as
well to help you improve the security of
your open source dependencies our
assured open source software service
provides over 250 packages across Java
and python in continuing to help secure
your pipelines I'm really excited to
announce Cloud build now supports salsa
level 3 bills
finally
to help secure the runtime environment
we're introducing a new set of security
features in gke gke can now help assess
your container security posture and give
you active security guidance for
customers on cloud run we're introducing
new enhancements to Cloud runs security
panel it now displays software supply
chain security insights when your
developers are building application
oftentimes they will need databases I'm
happy to introduce Cloud SQL security
recommender it can now automatically
monitor the security posture of your
databases alert you on potential
security vulnerabilities to make
multi-cloud easier for you we're
introducing a set of new features to our
anthos platform anthos customers can now
enjoy a unified management experience
everywhere from a single Google Cloud
console and to drive consistent security
governance and observability across a
fleet of clusters spanning all
environments whether on-prem hybrid or
multi-cloud
in addition ansos now supports VM
deployments for your Edge environments
and to help our customers develop and
operate more sustainably I am pleased to
announce that carbon footprint is now
generally available
carbon footprint introduces a new level
of transparency to support you in
meeting your climate goals integrating
and scaling your devops tool chain is a
challenge for many devops teams and for
that I am happy to announce our managed
service for Prometheus is now GA in
addition
to make continuous deployment easier for
you we added integration between Cloud
deploy and Cloud run and to make the use
of logs easier on Google Cloud I'm
excited to announce log analytics
through an Innovative partnership with
bigquery Cloud logging now allows your
devops teams to get more value out of
the logs through the power of SQL
queries
with these capabilities your
organization can adopt a more secure
intelligent and sustainable devops
practice on behalf of Jerome and I we
hope you have a great next 2022.
foreign